donc nous entendons à présent monsieur
Renaud villa qui est directeur de la
Caisse nationale d'assurance vieillesse
sur le projet de loi de finance
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
ottoman autrement dit sur la réforme des
retraites
c'est plus simple j'indique que ces
auditions fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et je vais vous laisser la parole
avant de nous rapporteur Elisabeth
Doisneau rapporteur général et René Paul
Savary rapporteur pour les retraites et
Sylvie vermeyer rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des finances puis les
commissaires ne vous adressent leurs
questions Monsieur le Directeur je vous
laisse la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs quelques propos liminaires
puisque vous m'y invitez en réponse au
questionnaire que vous avez bien voulu
m'envoyer hier évidemment je fournirai
l'ensemble des réponses des réponses
écrites
dans le prolongement de cette de cet
échange d'abord il y a une première
question sur la situation financière de
la branche vieillesse du régime général
le solde 2022 n'est pas encore connu par
encore consolider on l'estime à date à
1,8 milliards d'euros en solde négatif
après un seul négatif d'un virgule un
milliard d'euros en 2021
mais c'est là un seul de très très
provisoire
vous interrogez la CNAV en Suisse sur
l'incidence de la double mesure
paramétrique d'accélération de la
réforme des Touraine et d'augmentation
de l'âge légal porté à 64 ans je me suis
permis de vous proposer une référence
2032 qui est le point d'achèvement de la
réforme puisque la génération en 2060 la
génération pardon 1968 atteindra 64 ans
en 2032 et c'est la première génération
pour laquelle l'âge légal sera en 2032
l'effet de la réforme si on cumule les
économies liées au moindre dépense et
l'augmentation des cotisations l'effet
de la réforme et de 5,9 milliards
d'euros en euros 2020 pour le régime
général des composés en 4,4 milliards
d'euros de moindre prestations et 1,5
milliards d'euros de cotisations en plus
donc ça améliore le solde
et donc le solde à l'horizon 2032 du
régime général serait de 5 milliards
d'euros déficit de 5 milliards d'euros
au lieu des 10,8 milliards d'euros
projeter à date donc une amélioration
sensible d'un solde qui resterait
déficitaire puisque vous le savez dans
l'économie générale de la réforme il y a
également d'autres régimes impactés mais
il y a également des mesures de
contribution que je n'ai pas intégré
dans ce chiffrage puisque notamment la
branche vieillesse devrait être
destinataire de nouvelles cotisations
vous m'interrogez ensuite sur l'impact
de ces mesures paramétriques sur la
pension moyenne sur la pension moyenne
des nouveaux retraités on a un impact de
court terme sur les générations proches
de la retraite un impact moyen d'un
virgule 5% qui est inégalement réparti
qui est plus marqué cet impact favorable
pour les petites retraites moins
marquées pour les retraites plus
confortables et cet impact sur la
pension moyenne à moyen terme pour les
générations 1970 et au-delà atteindrait
2% avec les mêmes la même répartition
inégale plus favorable aux trois
premiers défils donc aux 30% des
Français les plus modestes
m'interroger sur la ventilation des
types de départ anticipé les départs en
retraite pour carré à long on représenté
18% de départ à la retraite en 2022 au
régime général les départs pour un
capacité permanent qui est la ce qu'on
surnommé à l'époque la pénibilité loi
2010 0,4 % les départs pour handicap 0,4
% de nos départs et les départs pour
pénibilité loi de 2014 qui était encore
en train de monter en charge qui monte
en charge lentement mais sûrement
représente à peu près l'équivalent 0,3%
de nos départs via le compte personnel
de prévention
s'agissant de la question de la question
plus large sur les extensions
spécifiques de dispositif sur
l'extension de du dispositif de départ
anticipé pour un capacité permanente
pénibilité loi 2010 les salles
d'assouplissement prévu dans le dans le
projet de loi augmenterait d'environ
individus le départ annuel au titre de
ce de ce dispositif c'est une hausse
d'environ 50% sur la pénibilité l'impact
de l'élargissement des critères de
pénibilité et des plafonds on n'a pas pu
dans les délais impartis mesurés mesuré
l'impact sur le nombre de départ et
enfin s'agissant des de l'intégration
des trimestres cotisés pour la retraite
carrière longue de l'intégration des
trimestres pour congés parental au sein
de la carrière longue ce serait deux à
trois mille femmes par an en plus qui
partiraient dans ce cadre-là à la
retraite
pour carrière longue
vous m'interrogez pardon j'essaye de
pardon pour la réponse un peu
mitraillette mais c'est pour laisser du
temps au débat et évidemment les écrits
seront plus complets vous m'interrogez
sur le coup du relèvement du minimum
contributif vous savez que le projet de
loi de financement rectificatif présente
deux dispositifs une augmentation en
deux états en deux étapes de 100 euros
du minimum contributif pour les nouveaux
retraités et la prestation
différentielle en quelque sorte
spécifique de 100 euros également à
chaque fois pour une carrière complète
pour les retraités actuels pour les
nouveaux pensionnés le dispositif
coûterait 500 millions en 2030 et il
continueraient ensuite à monter en
charge si on prend le flux et les
retraités actuels à l'horizon 2030 on
serait sur un coup de 1,3 milliards
puisque le gros du coup avant la montée
en charge du flux porte sur le porte sur
le stock assez logiquement
vous m'interrogez sur le pourcentage de
retraités qui bénéficie de ce fameux
minimum contributif et de l'impact à
date sur leur retraite c'est aujourd'hui
34% de nos retraités donc 4,8 millions
de retraités qui bénéficient du minimum
contributif et ça représente un impact
de 112 euros donc c'est ce fameux
minimum contributif l'impact moyen
aujourd'hui 112 euros en augmentation de
100 euros l'impact moyen mécaniquement
serait plus significatif
vous m'interrogez pour savoir si les
trimestres réputés cotisés pour la
carrière longue le sont également pour
le calcul du minimum contributif
ils ne le sont pas sauf après réformes
pour les trimestres parentaux et
congédans à VPF et Ava peut-être que
c'est prévu dans la réforme
vous m'interrogez je pense dans le cadre
des interrogations qui a pu avoir sur le
1200 euros l'articulation entre le 1200
euros et le minimum contributif vous
m'interrogez sur le montant de la
pension globale base puisqu'on
complémentaire pour une carrière
complète au SMIC il est actuellement de
1103 euros sur Cathy puisque le la
personne qui a pendant exactement toute
sa vie cotisée exactement au SMIC je
crois n'existe pas on est bien là sur
une modélisation telle que prévu par
l'eau 2003 donc aujourd'hui on est à
1103 euros brut dans ce cas type ce qui
explique du coup les 1200 euros puisque
1103 + 100 euros à peu de choses près
fait 1200
vous m'interrogez sur l'impact du
relèvement de 39000 à 100.000 euros du
seuil de récupération pour l'ASPA
n'est-ce pas vous le savez c'est le
minimum vieillesse donc un des frais en
euros court est lié au fait que on
récupère ensuite le montant sur
succession du minimum vieillesse dès
lors qu'il y a une succession supérieure
à 39000 €
cet impact est difficile à mesurer en
tout cas date en 2022 on a récupéré sur
ce fondement 117 millions d'euros donc
c'est une récupération que l'on mène
activement la loi qui nous l'impose
passez le seuil de 39000 à 100.000 euros
donc un seul beaucoup plus significatif
devrait sans doute réduire de manière
extrêmement significative le volume de
récupération que nous opérerions mais
sans avoir pu à date et je vous prie de
m'excuser effectuer un chiffrage un peu
plus fin
vous m'interrogez sur le nombre de
trimes de personnes qui aujourd'hui
bénéficient de trimestre au titre de la
VPF donc congé parental l'assurance
vieillesse des parents au foyer ce sont
aujourd'hui 1,8 millions de personnes
qui bénéficient chaque année de
trimestres de la VPF et vous
m'interrogez sur le nouvel Ava assurance
vieillesse des aidants tel qu'elle est
créée proposer des trucs créée pardon
dans le plfs rekificatif elle
concernerait selon nos chiffrage 100 000
personnes 100 000 bénéficiaires annuels
de ces cotisations versées par la
branche famille ce que de session versée
par la prochaine
la question 12 porte sur la mesure
relative aux travaux d'utilité
collective et assez contrats aidés des
années 80-90 qui n'apportait pas de
droit à retraite alors même qui est
reposaient sur une activité
le gouvernement ce sont des contrats que
l'on ne peut pas tracer et donc ils vont
reposer sur une déclaration de l'assuré
et le gouvernement dans son étude
d'impact à estimer le coup 400 millions
sur une hypothèse d'un taux de recours à
10%
cette hypothèse de taux de recours à 10%
me paraît prudente
elle peut s'expliquer par le fait qu'une
partie met des bénéficiaires n'auront
pas besoin auront déjà tout leur
trimestres qu'une partie des
bénéficiaires est sans doute déjà partie
à la retraite ce qui explique sans doute
cette réflexion en revanche évidemment
comme gestionnaire et comme celui qui
devra aller solliciter l'ensemble de ses
anciens bénéficiaires de contrat aidés
les années 80-90 pour valoriser leurs
droits retraite
se dit 10% évidemment mangage et
m'engage est vraiment éventuellement
aller au-delà le taux de recours me
semble prudent il vaut mieux partir sur
une hypothèse prudente mais comme
gestionnaire il me semble que je peux
exercer les digigences nécessaires pour
l'augmenter
mais sans pouvoir à date prendre
d'engagement
vous m'interrogez sur la part des
assurés qui sont au chômage lorsqu'il
liquide leur droit à la retraite au
régime général c'est 11%
je n'ai pas les derniers chiffres c'est
11% en 2020 ils vont interroger sur la
situation de l'emploi des seniors
notamment la catégorie évidemment du
régime général donc des salariés et
travailler indépendants
globalement mais vous le savez
parfaitement on a une forme de situation
très paradoxale en France le regard de
l'emploi des seniors on est au dessus de
la moyenne européenne pour le segment
d'avant 60 ans on est 55 59 ans on est
très en dessous la moyenne européenne
pour le segment des 64 des 60 à 64 ans
ceci explique sans doute à la fois par
des améliorations nécessaires de la
politique de l'emploi des seniors et
l'investissement des entreprises en ce
sens mais ça s'explique aussi assez
largement par l'effet d'éviction de 62
ans quand vous partez à la retraite à 62
ans mécaniquement vous n'êtes plus en
emploi et donc la très bonne performance
française sur l'emploi du Seigneur 55 59
ans il a très mauvaise performance de
l'employé junior sur la le segment 60 64
ans s'explique assez largement et assez
mécaniquement par l'âge légal à 62 ans
c'est ce qu'on a pu vérifier d'ailleurs
lors de la mise en œuvre de la loi
portant réforme des retraites du 9
novembre 2010 qui a porté l'âge légal de
60 à 62 ans et qui a mécaniquement en
quelque sorte augmenter l'emploi des
seniors ça c'est fort bien vérifier je
ne suis pas futurologue comme dirait ma
voisine que j'ai oublié de présenter qui
est en réalité l'autrice de tous ces
chiffrages qui est directrice
statistique et prospective des
recherches de la CNAV mais là dessus
cette translation en tout cas c'est
vérifiée par le par le passé
de l'incapacité de son organisation à
accepter un salarié senior à temps
partiel là où aujourd'hui l'employeur
est souverain et peut accorder ou
refuser le temps partiel
j'ai presque fini et je je vous prie de
m'excuser qu'il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de questions et j'ai essayé de
les ramasser mais j'ai peut-être été
trop trop
lapidaire et je vous prie par avance de
mon excuser
j'avais une question qui portait sur le
cumulon part retraite aujourd'hui on a
000 personnes qui font du cumu par
retraite c'est un nombre qui va
croissant qui a quasiment doublé en 10
ans et vous le savez le projet de
financement recticatif prévoit que ce
cumulant par retrait sera désormais
créateur de droit on estime l'impact au
terme de la montée en charge à 0,3
milliards pour les dépenses
supplémentaires du régime 0 3 milliards
liés aux pensions supplémentaires que
nous verserions aux salariés qui
auraient exercé un cube non par retraite
et enfin dernière question et
pardonnez-moi pour ce marathon de
réponse dernière question sur l'impact
sur la trajectoire financière du régime
de l'affiliation des
salariés naguère affiliés au régime
spéciaux
réponse de de Normand
à la fois pas d'impact puisque ce sont
des nouveaux cotisants qui s'ouvriront
de nouveaux droits retraites futurs donc
c'est finalement relativement
transparent et on l'a fait de la même
manière pour les cheminots il y a deux
ans de manière relativement transparente
en revanche les régimes spéciaux vont
voir leur assiette de cotisants et donc
leur ratio démographique fortement
déformée puisque ils vont avoir un
nombre de cotisants en diminution très
rapide alors que leur nombre de
retraités ne baissera pas sur la même
trajectoire et dans ce cadre là il est
envisageable des mécanismes de
compensation comme on le fait d'ailleurs
actuellement pour la SNCF puisque la
CNAV et la JR c'est une compensation
financière à la SNCF au régime spécial
de la SNCF pour atténuer en quelque
sorte le choc démographique mon seul
souhait
si les tentendable c'est que s'il
compensation démographique c'est
compensation il y a elle soit mesurée
sur le plan statistique et pas sur le
plan comptable parce que le législateur
lors du de la doucement du régime des
donc de dfdf pour faire vite avait
choisi un adossement comptable qui veut
dire que techniquement aujourd'hui nous
liquidons nous reliquidons nous
recalculons une pension fictive pour
tous les retraités des
IEG aujourd'hui pour la comparer à leur
pension réelle des régimes spéciales ce
qui fait qu'on fait le travail deux fois
pour de simples raisons comptables le
législateur pour la SNCF a prévu un
rapport statistique qui est tout aussi
robuste et beaucoup plus simple à
exercer puisqu'on évalue finalement
l'impact pour la démographie du régime
donc je me permets cette cette petite
supplique de simplification
administrative voilà ma présidente et
1000 pardon d'avoir été d'avoir été
aussi bavard je vous prie Marie
merci Monsieur le Directeur vous avez
balayé effectivement rapidement toutes
les questions qui vous avez été soumises
je vais dans un premier temps laisser la
parole à nous rapporteurs Elisabeth
Doisneau rapporteur général René Paul
Savary et Sylvie vermeiller pour la
commission des finances
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur c'est vrai que nous avons
généralement une version un petit peu
différente parce que la plupart du temps
nous attendons des propos liminaires et
là vous avez répondu à l'ensemble du
questionnaire qui vous était proposé et
auquel nous attendions de réponse mais
qui aurait pu venir après cette audition
parce que justement il faut laisser à
nos collègues la place voilà aux
réflexions alors la réforme des
retraites c'est en quelque sorte une
réforme qui constitue un point important
du collectif or chacun dans cette
question attend la réponse individuelle
à son propre ressort c'est c'est toute
la difficulté
sur la question de sauver le système
c'est vrai que nous attendions comme je
l'ai fait moi-même et mes collègues et
peut-être un certain nombre des
dessinateurs comment juste fiez-vous
finalement
le titre du rapport justice équilibre
progresse c'est ça qui aurait beaucoup
compté parce que en réalité c'est les
mots qui reviennent aussi dans les
manifestations
cette réforme est injuste être brutale
etc donc moi j'aurais aimé que vous
vous arrêtiez sur justement la
justification en quelque sorte de de
cette réforme c'est pour ça que je vais
vous demander d'avoir plus de précisions
sur la situation financière en fait de
la branche vieillesse
est-elle à ce point en déficit et avec
quelle rapidité parce que c'est souvent
ce qui revient on nous dit que les
choses sont pas si grave que ça que
comment finalement il y a un mauvais
passage et qu'après ça pourrait être
mieux donc je voudrais qu'on s'arrête
précisément sur cette trajectoire et en
quoi elle est quelque part tragique
parce que effectivement si on veut
sauver ce régime par répartition il y a
des mesures à prendre et le Sénat n'a
pas été le dernier à le dire depuis cinq
années donc je voudrais que vous
arrêtiez là-dessus précisément et puis
pour prendre un peu de hauteur si je
puis dire les éléments paramétriques de
la réforme proposée vous semble-t-il de
nature à assurer à long terme justement
la soutenabilité du système de retraite
en général et du régime général en
particulier donc vraiment s'attacher à
répondre à cette question et vous vous
apprêtez à intégrer les salariés de
nouveaux régimes je parlais de la RATP
de l'iog est-ce que vous êtes prêts sur
le plan technique est-ce que vous avez
je dirais les ressources humaines
suffisantes cela s'est-il d'ailleurs
bien passé vous avez évoqué la SNCF mais
est-ce que ça s'est bien passé pour la
SNCF et à votre connaissance cela
modifie-t-il les modes de rémunération
des des assurés concernés
des entreprises concernées je voudrais
m'arrêter aussi sur la deuxième question
qui était de notre questionnaire sur
l'incidence du report à 64 ans de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à compter de la
génération 1968 on est beaucoup pas
interrogé des uns les autres par des
femmes qui ont eu un certain nombre
d'enfants et qui ont leur nombre de
trimestres et qui sont dans cette
période là 60 et 1 enfin ennemis
si on peut dire
jusque comment à la génération 68 et qui
nous disent on va être obligé de
travailler plus enfin elles ont
l'impression que leur trimestre de de
congé maternité sont écrasés en fait par
cette nouvelle réforme et est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il y a des efforts que
nous pourrions faire justement dans
notre débat parlementaire pour améliorer
la situation de ces femmes qui ont
vraiment le sentiment d'être un peu les
comment les victimes de
cette proposition de réforme et puis
pour le reste je vais laisser mes
collègues vous posez d'autres questions
si vous voulez bien on prend les
questions des trois rapporteurs
merci oui quelques
précisions supplémentaires il va y avoir
des personnes qui effectivement vont
avoir leur 43 années je commence à
imaginons à 20 ans elle rentre pas dans
le dispositif carrière longue
elles arrivent à 63 ans elles ont leur
durée de cotisation elles n'ont pas
l'âge légal elles vont attendre un an de
plus la jegal est-ce que vous pensez que
pour les inciter adoucir un peu cette
cette allongement on pourrait envisager
une surcote pour ces personnes là n'ont
pas établi à partir de la géniale mais à
partir de la durée
d'activité
contrairement au dispositifs actuels
est-ce que vous pourriez chiffrer ce que
cela représente alors pas dans le quart
d'heure mais dans les deux jours de
façon à avoir une estimation de ce type
de ce type de mesure en ce qui concerne
les régimes complémentaires est-ce que
vous pensez qu'ils vont être associés
aux efforts
collectif qui sont demandés dans un
certain nombre de dispositifs notamment
avec celui du myco et puis une autre
question
pour reprendre une question qui avait
été d'ailleurs posée par une de nos
collègues combien le personnes
réellement dépendant de votre régime
vont être bénéficiaire des 1200 euros
ceux qui sont à carrière longue
au SMIC qui remplissent toutes les
conditions combien cela fait de
personnes
sur le plan du nombre
voilà quelques précisions simplement
merci
madame la Présidente
quelques quelques compléments vous avez
abordé plusieurs sujets sur lesquels je
souhaiterais des précisions tout d'abord
sur
le
sol de global sur la blanche branche
vieillesse vous avez peu parlé des
ressources complémentaires qui
pourraient abonder cette cette branche
vieillesse donc est-ce que vous avez des
estimations
ensuite
moi j'ai beaucoup de questions sur les
éventuels compensations
compensation régime spéciaux
vous avez évoqué cette piste ça
m'intéresse beaucoup est-ce que c'est
compensations pourraient se mettre en
oeuvre par exemple pour un régime comme
celui de la RATP qui s'ouvre à la
concurrence comment est-ce que vous
voyez ces compensations se mettre en
oeuvre je pense aussi à l'estimation des
compensations
concernant tous les contrats actuels
fonctions publiques puisqu'il y a un
débat aujourd'hui sur une éventuelle
hausse
du taux CNRACL et voilà comment
s'articule ces compensations comment
elles sont prévues et puis dernière
petite question c'est sur le cumulant
pour la retraite vous avez dit que il y
aurait un impact je crois de 0,3
milliards pour les pensions
complémentaires mais il y aura aussi des
cotisations supplémentaires est-ce que
0,3 milliards c'est tout confondu ou
quel est l'impact du coup si 0,3
milliards c'est seulement les pensions
supplémentaires combien pour les pour
les cotisations supplémentaires merci
merci Monsieur le Directeur je vous
laisse répondre à cette première salle
de question et puis ensuite on ouvrira
nos collègues
merci beaucoup à la présidente et Émile
pardon même leur rapporteur général du
coup d'avoir failli dans ma présentation
je vais à nouveau être être décevant et
je vous prie mon excusé il n'appartient
pas évidemment de de commenter ou de
justifier les termes de l'étude d'impact
en revanche sur le sol de financier du
régime parce qu'effectivement on entend
beaucoup de choses assez variées donc là
moi effectivement je suis
donc je prends le solde des régimes j'ai
des recettes j'ai des dépenses le solde
du régime général il est là
c'est à dire que il est en phase à la
courbe orange
évidemment on pourra vous la communiquer
et la pente de la courbe orange c'est
une piste rouge
voir une piste noire et là les chiffres
les chiffres sont têtus ce sont les
chiffres du conseil de rotation des
retraites parce que il y a pas l'ombre
d'une feuille de papier à cigarette
entre la CNAV et le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites simplement
pour moi pour mesurer un régime de
retraite il faut regarder ces recettes
ses dépenses et donc on a une évolution
on a des perspectives de soldes qui sont
effectivement extrêmement
[Musique]
dégradé là dessus l'horizon de la
réforme
tel que le gouvernement l'a indiqué
c'est un horizon 2030 et à 2030 alors je
vais vous donner des chiffres 2032 mais
c'est la même la même économie générale
à 2030 la réforme boucle effectivement
puisque vous l'avez dit très justement
il y a la fois des mesures de moindre
dépense des financements nouveaux et des
mesures de dépenses de dépenses
nouvelles et au total pour le coup à la
fois pour le régime général mais en tout
régime nous sommes complètement
convergent avec avec les chiffrages de
l'étude impact du gouvernement pour une
simple et bonne raison et la modestie
parceque en souffrir c'est que les
chiffrages ont été réalisés par les dans
une grande majorité par les équipes de
Pascal Breuil et là-dessus ils sont
parfaitement parfaitement robustes donc
la justification de la réforme il
m'appartient évidemment pas de je suis
parfaitement neutre par rapport à à la
réforme en revanche à la question y
a-t-il un déficit croissant du régime
général ou de l'agrégat régime général
plus FSV la réponse effectivement mais
alors générale et pleinement affirmative
sans aucun doute possible et cette
réponse est évidemment
pleinement partagée avec le conseil de
rotation des retraites vous m'interrogez
sur
l'impact de l'intégration de nouveaux
cotisant alors l'impact en gestion et
relativement simple je mets un
relativement c'est relativement simple
puisque finalement nous avons déjà 22
millions de cotisants quelques dizaines
de milliers de cotisants en plus ne
seront pas très complexes et d'ailleurs
la réforme de la SNCF c'est passé sans
aucun bruit parce que justement les
nouveaux cotisants ont été affiliés sans
difficulté on a malgré tout un point de
vigilance particulier mais c'est des
travaux en gestion à construire qui est
au fait que les régimes spéciaux vont
garder leur identité propre notamment en
s'agissant de la branche maladie
invalidité et que de ce fait il va
falloir qu'on construise des échanges en
gestion avec les régimes spéciaux leur
branche maladie invalidité puisque on
valide des trimestres au titre de la
maladie de la maternité de la validité
qui seront pris en charge par les
régimes spéci ce sont des échanges à
construire aujourd'hui notre
interlocuteur principal c'est le régime
général d'assurance maladie la CNAM
c'est des échanges enfin rien à
surmontable en tout cas c'est un point
de vigilance évidemment en gestion qu'il
faudra que l'on
sur
les
sur les trimestres les trimestres pour
les femmes et les femmes qui finalement
ont leur trimestre éventuellement à 63
ans et demi 61 ans et demi l'exemple que
vous avez pris madame le rapporteur
général là dessus je me permets à un
rappel et pardon si cela semble superflu
il y a trois types
et parfois la sémantique peut compliquer
les choses vous avez trois types
davantage liés à la maternité le coup en
retraite un bien entendu le congé
maternité c'est à dire le fait que
pendant une période la femme s'arrête de
travailler à son congé maternité et
ensuite on le souhaite si elle le
souhaite de reprendre recontre à
travailler le congé parental qu'on
appelle l'AVPF sur une expression très
années 70 assurance vieillesse des
parents au foyer et qui en fait la prise
en charge du congé parental par des
cotisations dédiées de la branche
famille versée à la branche vieilleuse
et les majorations de durée d'assurance
qui conduisent schématiquement les
femmes à avoir 8 trimestres donc deux
ans
d'assurance vieillesse supplémentaire
pour chaque enfant
ces trois dispositifs sont très
différents le congé maternité
aujourd'hui est totalement transparent
en retraite le congé maternité une femme
qui est en congé maternité donc il
s'arrête dans le cadre du congé légal ou
de prolongation c'est période de proje
maternité sont non seulement recevables
dans la durée d'assurance mais son
receva comme durée cotisée et depuis la
réforme de 2010 sont prises en charge
pour le salaire annuel moyen
c'est-à-dire qu'ils compris on va
considérer que son salaire entre
guillemets son indemnisation de congé
maternité rentre dans son salaire de
référence donc le congé maternité en
lui-même est transparent
le congé parental la VPF
et transparent en termes de durée
d'assurance puisque la CAF cotise nous
envoie des cotisations pour pour la
bénéficiaire en revanche aujourd'hui il
est il n'est pas pris en compte pour les
carrières longues et n'est pas pris en
compte pour le minimum contributif et là
c'est une des évolutions proposées dans
le projet d'accinancement explicatif
c'est de prendre en compte une partie de
ces trimestres de congé parental donc
pour lequel la mère pour faire vite
c'était 95% des cas interrompons son
activité pour prendre en charge de ses
enfants propose de prendre en charge ces
périodes de congé parental pour les
carrières longues en partie et pour le
minimum contributif donc pour le bonus
de pension en quelque sorte que
reprendre le micro et il y a un
troisième étage
qui la majoration durée d'assurance ce
fameux bonus parce que c'est vraiment un
bonus ça ne vient pas s'imputer sur une
année plus spécifique qui est un bonus
de deux années sur l'ensemble de la
carrière qui sont positionnés un peu
hors sol en quelque sorte on les gère au
moment du passage à la retraite où on
rajoute 8 trimestres par enfant donc si
vous avez eu trois enfants ça vous
rajoute 6 années bonus en quelque sorte
c'est là dessus ces trois dispositifs
sont différents et là-dessus sur la ce
bonus en quelque sorte de durée
d'assurance effectivement ce bonus n'est
pas pris en compte au titre des carrés
longues ne l'était pas
auparavant et là-dessus dans le projet
de financement actif il n'est pas
proposé de l'intégrer mais je vais me
permettre cette précision parce que
parfois la sémantique peut induire des
complexités parce que si on prend les
majorations de durée d'assurance
une femme de trois enfants qui était un
modèle assez classique surtout dans la
génération qui partent aujourd'hui à la
retraite c'est 6 ans on parle de 6 ans
donc si on suit le calcul en quelque
sorte ça voudrait dire que elle devrait
partir à 58 ans m'appartient pas de me
prononcer sur l'opportunité pour une
mère de famille de partir à 58 ans mais
l'effet est celui-ci on parle pas du
congé maternité qui en général ne dure
pas six ans ou alors ce sont des couches
légèrement complexes pardon pour pour la
boutade de ce fait et là dessus je crois
qu'il y a eu parfois peut-être des
incompréhensions
dans le projet loi de financement
explicatif de la sécurité sociale avant
après les femmes partent plutôt que les
hommes
l'impact de la réforme ne modifie pas
cet état de fait la retraite moyenne des
femmes augmente plus que la retraite
moyenne des hommes
c'est l'impact pour le coup de ce de ce
projet de loi de financement éducatif en
revanche
en revanche et c'est ce qui apparaît
justement dans le fait c'est ce qui
apparaît dans
c'est ce qui apparaît dans dans le fait
que
l'âge de départ à la retraite des femmes
tant à se rapprocher de l'âge de départ
à la retraite des hommes mais cela n'est
pas la conséquence du projet loi de
financement avec les social c'est la
conséquence du travail des femmes c'est
la conséquence d'un fait inéluctable
imparable qui est qu'en 2021 de course
se sont croisées la durée d'assurance
des femmes et la durée d'assurance des
hommes jusqu'en 2021 les hommes avaient
une durée d'assurance supérieure à celle
des femmes à compter 2021 et au-delà si
j'en crois les prévisions de ma voisine
mais j'ai rarement été déçu par ses
prévisions
la durée d'assurance des femmes restera
supérieure à celle des hommes ah c'est
pour lever en quelque sorte une forme de
il y a la loi il y a les effets de la
loi mais il y a aussi finalement des
tendances longues qui font que l'âge de
départ à la retraite qui soit à 60 62 64
67 que sais-je l'âge de départ à la
retraite des femmes se rapproche de
celui des hommes mais parce que le
comportement au travail en quelque sorte
des femmes se rapproche de celui des
hommes c'est-à-dire que les femmes ont
maintenant celles qui part la retraite
née dans les années 60 ont des carrières
qui ressemblent de plus en plus en
termes de profil de durée d'assurance
aux carrière masculine
les questions de de du sénateur Savary
du rapporteur sur la question de la
surcotte finalement qui permettrait
d'atténuer en quelque sorte ou
d'accompagner des personnes qui auraient
le taux plein à 63 ans aurait tout leur
trimestre à 63 ans le chiffrage est très
facile et je ne vais même pas devoir
solliciter ma voisine la surcote est
actuellement neutre c'est à dire que une
année de surcote et transparente pour un
régime de retraite ce qui veut dire que
si on fait partir quelqu'un 63 ans avec
à partir de 63 ans il dit tu ne pars pas
à la retraite encore tu partiras 64 ans
mais tu vas avoir une surcote de 5%. ça
veut dire que ça revient ipso facto à
faire partir la personne à 63 ans c'est
la même chose puisque l'actuellement
neutre de la surcote elle est calibrée
ainsi une surcope si vous partez à 60
aujourd'hui à 64 ans le 62 ans vous avez
10% de bonus de pension mais qui
correspond exactement sur le plan actuel
au fait que vous avez renoncé la partie
à 62 ans et donc du coup on vous
améliore d'autant on vous améliore de
10% pour prendre un exemple votre
retraite futur et en fait c'est un
calcul un calcul actuel assez simple
mais mes robustes puisque si vous partez
à 64 ans vous allez pas avoir 24 ans de
retraite mais 22 et donc on vous major
d'autant votre retraite pour que
finalement l'espérance globale de
retraite sur l'ensemble de votre durée
de vie à la retraite soit la même et
donc de ce fait ça reviendrait en fait
finalement à par exemple à mettre l'âge
légal à 63 ans ce serait la même la même
chose vous soulevez un point une
question
deux questions
complexes parce qu'elle sorte de mon
champ de mais elles sont de première
importance c'est effectivement
l'articulation base et complémentaire la
loi de 2003 avait fixé un objectif qui
est un objectif politique ce qui fait
qu'il n'a pas été enfin c'est pas que
politique qui soit pas respecté mais
c'est un objectif non normatif qui était
le maintien de d'une carrière complète
au SMIC à 85% du SMIC aujourd'hui on en
a des crochets de quasiment 100 euros
l'inconvénient en tout cas la
particularité vous l'avez se souvient
très justement sur le rapporteur c'est
qu'une retraite c'est une base plus une
complémentaire
vous le savez gérer par les partenaires
sociaux et de ce fait
constituer un angle mort de de ce point
là
le dispositif prévu en premier joueur
prévoit d'augmenter de 100 euros le
minimum contributif et donc de faire
porter sur la seule base le décrochement
observé depuis 2003 parce que c'est ça
en fait on dit depuis 2003 l'objectif
n'a pas franchement été atteint à
diminuer année après année en réalité
parce que c'est pas un coup brutal mais
progressivement le 85 % il y a eu un
écart qui s'est creusé du fait de la
base et de la complémentaire parce que
la complémentaire a également sous
indexé voire même plus que la base dans
le cas l'objectif a décroché
le président projet de lottignancement
propose de faire porter l'ensemble des
forces de rattrapage au régime de base
ce qui est assez logique en droit
puisque évidemment le législateur n'est
pas compétent sur le régime
complémentaire en revanche vous le
soulignez très justement monsieur le
rapporteur ça peut poser au bout d'un
moment un problème de financement parce
que si c'est la base qui prend l'effort
seul une base qui dans une situation
financière qui n'est pas des plus des
plus riante ça peut effectivement
interroger en termes d'éventuelles
transfert et de ce fait c'est exactement
la même le même la même réponse pour les
les 1200 euros je peux vous dire à
l'unité près combien de personnes vont
bénéficier de ce coup de pouce de 100
euros pour une carrière complète et donc
il sera proratisé en fonction de la
durée cotisée mais de ce coup de pouce
pour une carrière complète c'est 1,8
millions de personnes de mémoire
j'essaie de retrouver le chiffre mais
sur le
ceux qui ont 1200 euros moi la base je
ne commande pas la complémentaire ça
pourrait faire partie de mes résultats
mais la suite du coup la base la base on
va faire un booster c'est comme ça qui
écrit la loi enfin la loi et mieux
écrite mais la loi dit pour le stock on
va augmenter jusqu'à 100 euros en
fonction de la durée cotisée les
retraites la retraite de base la
complémentaire ensuite la dépendre
d'infiniment d'un infiniment grand
nombre de paramètres
pour le coup je suis un Canadien il y a
des gens qui vont être au-delà de 1200
euros avec le booster c'est certain
d'autres qui vont être en deçà parce que
le régime complémentaire non seulement
je ne pilote pas mais ça c'est c'est
évidemment une nécessité mais en outre
vous le savez parfaitement le taux de
cotisation régime complémentaire varie
d'une entreprise l'autre et donc le
nombre d'acquisitions de points au
régime complémentaire agir Carco et
variable sont les entreprises chaque
accord d'entreprise permet des
surcotisations etc c'est pour ça que la
loi de 2003
avait fixé un cas type en disant ça a
l'air carrière pardon complète au SMIC
sur le taux de cotisation nominale donc
le plus bas d'agir Carco 1200 euros
enfin 85 % du SMIC pardon on a décroché
par rapport à la loi le projet de
financement
rétablit en quelque sorte mais plus 100
euros sur la seule base pour le flux et
pour le stock pour retrouver cette
intention politique de la loi 2003 et le
projet de loi de financement social fait
de l'objectif politique de la 2003 un
objectif à un impératif normatif
puisque le micro sera dorénavant arrimer
sur le SMIC donc ah mais c'est le
dispositif légal en revanche le
dispositif légal ne fait porter que sur
la base c'est à dire que si demain je
crois pas que ce soit l'intention des
partenaires sociaux mais si demain le
régime complémentaire baisse de 20 %
toutes les portions complémentaires
l'objectif redéchera mais parce que la
loi ne peut pas imposer de règles à au
régime complémentaire qui sont gérés
vous le savez dans le cas d'une
gouvernance paritaire je pense que c'est
évidemment un cas d'école je crois pas
que les personnes baisser les retraites
mais voilà en tout cas force de
constater que le projet de financement
s'appuie sur ce qui est du champ du
législateur le régime de base pour le
passer c'est la base qui porte le
rattrapage
pour l'avenir
il reste à espérer qu'effectivement base
et complémentaire permettent ensemble de
tenir l'objectif j'ai pas d'inquiétude
dans le sujet mais en tout cas la loi ne
peut pas être prescriptif en la matière
pour
essayer de voir plus de précision sur
les personnes qui sont pris en compte
dans le stock combien estimez-vous
puisque ça répond de vous de pension de
plus de 100 euros que vous allez verser
millions de personnes qui vont
bénéficier du dispositif mais pour bon
nombre d'entre elles
la mesure est proratisée donc elle
n'auront pas 100 euros combien de
personnes auront 100 €
. alors pour le coup on aura donc 1,8
millions de personnes qui auront la
mesure stock en gros 60% de femmes 40 %
d'hommes
se sont un pourcent 39%, enfin peu
importe un million de femmes 700 000
hommes
l'augmentation moyenne devrait être de
l'ordre de 70 euros si j'ai bonne
moyenne si bonne et moi pardon
là je dis les chiffres le chiffre de
tête en revanche la ventilation fine je
ne l'ai pas et je n'ai pas par refus
d'obstacle je n'ai pas pour la simple et
bonne raison que pour mettre en oeuvre
ce dispositif et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
prévoit le préjolais le financement la
sécurité sociale puisque vous l'avez vu
la le projet de loi de financement donne
jusqu'à septembre 2024 pour achever les
opérations pourquoi parce que avant 2007
je ne sais pas ce qu'est une durée
cotisée toutes les personnes qui sont
parties avant à la retraite avant 2007
c'est à dire avant la majoration du
minimum contributif prévu par la loi
2003 mais avec un délai d'entrée en
vigueur nécessaire en gestion avant 2007
la notion de trimestre cotisée au sens
du minium contributif majoré n'existait
pas une notion qui n'existait pas dans
des retraites que vous liquides dans les
années 2000 1990 franchement je veux pas
insulter le législateur que vous êtes
mais le droit de la retraite était un
peu plus simple en 1990 qu'en 2023 par
conséquent on a énormément donné qui
sont totalement indisponibles
aujourd'hui sur des personnes qui sont
partis à la retraite en 1990 qui pour
certains sont encore ont encore bon pied
bon œil elles ont travaillé dans les
années 50 autant vous dire que
reconstituer leur guerre cotisée avec
des déclarations employeur qui tenaient
sur une feuille de papier qui n'était
pas franchement informatisée parce que
dans les années 50 il est même pas les
cartes perforides ça va être un petit un
petit un petit boulot ce qui fait que
comme un petit peu de travail je pardon
pour cette amiarité mais ce qui fait que
pour le coup on peut avoir les
chiffrages globaux sur les retraités
mais l'impact unitaire on est mais parce
qu'on a c'est un vrai angle mort c'est
la première fois qu'on a une mesure qui
touche tous les retraités en fonction de
leur carrière et donc le on va on pourra
mettre en oeuvre ce qu'on connaît bien
en quelque sorte ceux qui sont partis
après 2006 septembre 2023 sans problème
et les autres progressivement va devoir
recréer en quelque sorte recréer leur
ils sont comme ça
qui est qui qui est un puits un puit de
de savoir je me sur la moyenne le
montant moyen le montant moyen des
musiciens du stock on est sur 680 euros
en moyenne ventilé en 760 pour les
hommes et 540 pour les pour les pour les
hommes
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer pour
Madame pour ces manches
et redonner vos chiffres
alors du coup les chiffres donc sur là
où je parle bien de la mesure stock
exactement donc un million 8 ventilé 1,1
million de femmes 700 000 hommes les
femmes donc auront en moyenne 760 euros
annuel évidemment et les hommes 540
euros annuel en moyenne et du coup
moyenne homme femme 680
évidemment on joindre on ajoutera tout
ça tout ça à nos à nos écritures
à vos à vos questions sur
sur la question de la décompensation
sur la compensation des questions de la
compensation des régimes spéciaux pour
le coup je pense que ce sera vraiment
par cet à côté du cas par cas en
fonction et vous l'avez dit très
justement du profil des régimes le
régime spécial par exemple de la RATP et
déjà assez largement je crois financé
par l'impôt et par conséquent il
appartiendra peut-être pas à la cnaval
de faire jouer la compensation
démographique mais là ce sera des
travaux à instruire je pense dans le
cadre également d'une concertation
technique avec les régimes au-delà d'une
concertation politique mais clairement
vous avez raison dans ce débat devra
rentrer en considération également la
question de l'ouverture à la concurrence
et de ne pas fausser en quelque sorte
cette ouverture à la concurrence sur le
champ des contractuels de la fonction
publique il est prévu effectivement une
augmentation de la cotisation
retraite pour les la scène Racl donc les
les contractuels les pardon les agents
publics des hôpitaux et des
collectivités territoriales
là-dessus c'est sans impact sans
incidence sur le le du régime général et
enfin sur le cumulant par retraite vous
avez raison le 0,3 milliards madame la
rapporteur ne concerne que les dépenses
nouvelles
en face vous avez parfaitement raison il
y a des cotisations
toutefois c'est cotisations existent
déjà et donc c'est une dépense
supplémentaire pour le régime de
retraite puisque aujourd'hui on perçoit
déjà des cotisations au titre du
document par retraite mais qui ne sont
pas
génératrices de droit donc c'est une
dépense nette en revanche si on fait
cotisation moins retraite supplémentaire
je pense que la mesure est quasi
équilibrée sauf que comme les
cotisations existent déjà c'est une
dépense supplémentaire en quelque sorte
à intégrer dans l'équilibre global de la
réforme en revanche si la situation
avait toujours été comme celle-ci les
cotisations auraient globalement
normalement équilibré les les dépenses
voilà pardon pour une réponse là aussi
un peu un peu un peu équilibrée mais
comme jusqu'ici c'est des cotisations
qui n'apportait aucun droit c'est des
cotisations dites de solidarité il faut
qu'on fasse que il faudra se mettre une
ressource pour financer les 300 millions
d'euros qu'on estime être le coût de la
de la mesure merci beaucoup madame
présidente pardon j'ai été trop bavard
[Musique]
regardons les ressources supplémentaires
de la branche vieillesse vous avez pas
parlé de cette question là
-dessus sur les ressources
supplémentaires à la branche vieillesse
pour le coup alors le ce sont on les a
pas intégrés dans les dans les
projections financières ce sont celles
de l'étude impact du gouvernement il y a
de mémoire à transfert de la branche un
transfert de cotisation de la branche
ATMP à hauteur quasiment d'un milliard
d'un milliard d'euros
ou quasi 800 millions oui pardon j'ai
pas j'ai pas j'ai pas regardé le chiffre
précis
on pourra vous faire le tableau complet
mais comme les attributions
supplémentaires de ressources finalement
nos relèvent pas du pilotage du régime
on les a pas intégrés dans nos
chiffrages mais il y a effectivement une
série de ressources complémentaires qui
devrait venir abonder le régime le
régime général
merci Monsieur le Directeur une série de
trois questions dans l'ordre madame
Lupin puis madame pensé Monge et
Monsieur Hainaut madame Lubin merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur effectivement pour pour des
collègues qui ne sont pas rompus à ces
dossiers là
votre votre propos liminaire était un
peu ardu et donc je demande à madame la
Présidente s'il serait possible que nous
ayons par écrit les questions qui ont
été posées et les réponses que vous nous
avez apportées ce qui permettrait à
chacun de réfléchir sur les chiffres que
vous nous avez donnés alors premièrement
j'aimerais Monsieur le Directeur que
je
il y a pas comme vous dites entre le
corps et la CNAV
l'espace d'un papier à cigarette sauf
que les chiffres sont pas les mêmes
puisque dans le rapport du corps on nous
donne un excédent de 3 milliards en 2022
et il me semble avoir entendu que vous
vous d'un déficit d'un milliard 8 donc
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquiez la
différence
ensuite je vous aide donc directeur de
la CNAV donc quand vous dites que au
final à l'échéance 2032 ça sera 5
milliards 800 millions d'euros de mieux
pour les caisses c'est je le dis au
collègue c'est un chiffre à mettre en
rapport avec les dépenses qui ont été
aussi prévues sur d'autres chapitres qui
ne relèvent pas de la CNAV je parle bien
évidemment des des aides sociales
alors moi je voudrais savoir alors
dernière remarque aussi c'est que vous
dites donc il y a pas l'ombre d'un
papier à cigarette entre vous sauf que
vous vous utilisez les termes
extrêmement dégradés quand vous parlez
des soldes futurs et que le corps lui
écrit noir sur blanc que la trajectoire
n'est pas en n'est pas en danger puisque
les hommes parlent de sol uniquement les
autres parlent de part du PIB
de par des retraites dans le PIB ce qui
veut quand même bien dire qu'on peut
avoir des interprétations différentes
qu'on peut avoir des interprétations
différentes même avec des chiffres
adéquats bon moi je voudrais savoir
est-ce que vous avez chiffré
ce qu'on vous a demandé de chiffrer
est-ce que vous pouvez chiffrer voilà un
impact d'une intégration des trimestres
qui sont attribués aux femmes non pas
pour les
non pas pour les congés parentaux mais
simplement pour les maternités est-ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer que dans le
cadre de cette réforme les femmes qui à
62 ans ont tout leur trimestres ou non
pas tout leur trimestre mais ont avec
deux trois enfants un certain nombre de
trimestres pour enfants est-ce qu'on
pourrait les leur attribuer de telle
sorte qu'elle ne soit pas obligée de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans parce que si
elles arrivent à 64 ans la plupart
d'entre elles auront perdu le bénéfice
de ces trimestres de maternité j'espère
que j'arrive à même René Paul France le
sourcil c'est mauvais signe ça veut dire
que je me suis pas bien fait comprendre
bon alors ça veut dire que quand une
femme arrive à 62 ans
et qu'il lui manque des trimestres mais
que elle a eu deux enfants elle a 16
trimestres et ça peut lui permettre du
coup de prendre sa retraite à 60 ans
mais si cette femme si c'est reporté à
74 ans du coup cette trimestre il lui
servent plus à grand chose du coup elle
a bien travaillé pour la nation merci au
revoir voilà et donc est-ce qu'il est
possible de de calculer l'impact pour
savoir combien ça coûterait si on lui
permet à 62 ans avec ses trimestres de
maternité de ne pas atteindre jusqu'à 64
ans bon René Paul a compris donc je dois
être voilà
voilà bon combien ça coûterait est-ce
que c'est possible vous avez parlé des
trucs ça peut paraître anecdotique mais
on a été saisi par un certain nombre de
personnes qui aujourd'hui veulent
valider leur retraite et voilà donc
j'ai noté qui est comment c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'on va vraiment leur compenser
les les cotisations qui n'ont pas été
versées est-ce qu'on va le faire j'ai
envie de dire presque à l'euro près bon
merci Madame pensé Monge
oui bon alors beaucoup de choses ont été
dit par ma collègue moi je voudrais
quand même revenir vraiment sur le micro
effectivement
enfin j'aimerais que vous me disiez si
j'ai bien compris déjà à savoir que
effectivement
la mesure stock et totalement totalement
à la charge de la base puisque on va pas
les complémentaires vont pas et c'est ça
que vous proratisez ou pas que vous
estimez à 70 euros bon vous avez dit les
chiffres etc
ça c'est le stock ok mais dans l'avenir
pour ce qui est du flux on est bien
d'accord voilà quand on dit à combien de
personnes vont être impacter là les
complémentaires
reviennent dans le calcul je veux dire
c'est pas comme pour le stock le groupe
d'experts sur le SMIC ce fameux groupe
d'experts qui chaque année dit les mêmes
choses mais enfin c'est de toujours
voilà
dit quand même une chose intéressante
c'est que il y a très peu alors moi j'ai
pas retenu le chiffre ça doit être 6 %
des des smicards enfin qui qui font une
carrière complète au SMIC et c'est même
pas le SMIC c'est 1,1 du SMIC un dont il
parle c'est à dire le SMIC un peu donc
de fait
quand
la personne à sa carrière complète on
est bien d'accord que la personne homme
ou femme concernée devra avoir fait 40
ans 43 ans de cotisation et attendre
quand même 64 ans elle va quand même
deux ans de plus cette ce fameux mico
qui est une mesure de progrès social
là pour le coup je veux dire on a
calculé le coût global de des
générations qui vont venir qui sont aux
portes des retraites si on a calculé le
coût global c'est qu'on a la
distribution
une moyenne on peut pas ça fait deux
fois qu'on pose la question de la
distribution
de cette mycose sur les générations 55
61 qui vont venir
le bal j'aimerais bien d'ailleurs que
enfin le coup évalué j'aimerais que vous
me le redisez compte tenu que voilà vu
les faibles personnes qui ont toutes les
conditions et qui sont restées au SMIC
ou 1,1 du SMIC voilà si vous arrivez à
le chiffrer vous avez donc la
possibilité de faire de nous donner la
distribution
voilà moi c'est j'insiste là dessus
parce que effectivement autant sur la
mesure stock enfin on s'en félicite
c'est une sorte de rattrapage d'une vous
l'avez dit du comment dire
d'un objectif politique qui avait pas
été transformé en
obligation donc bon tant mieux c'est se
rattrapage là mais pour les nouveaux en
quoi voilà c'est une en quoi c'est une
mesure sociale de la loi que nous allons
voter combien ça
que nous allons voter contre ou pour
quand on va voter la loi on va la voter
si on a le temps de la voter vu le temps
un parti bien
très rapidement aussi vous dites bon
vous faites vous faites votre l'effet
horizon bon ça vous savez ça vous
regarde mais je veux dire dans dans le
taux d'activité qui a augmenté il n'y a
pas simplement le
changement de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits il y a aussi la durée requise de
cotisations qui a poussé le taux le taux
en emploi il y a aussi ce que vous avez
dit un peu plus tard l'arrivée massive
des générations notamment de femmes qui
ont travaillé donc forcément ne
serait-ce que par l'effet générationnel
le taux le taux d'activité
entre 60 62 ans 63 ans était poussé
c'était un effet mécanique donc il n'est
pas ce que je vous dis et j'aimerais
bien d'ailleurs si ça a été pensé ça
parce que tout le monde parle de l'effet
horizons quand on parle d'un effet
horizon on dit comment scientifiquement
la calculer donc il faut qu'il soit
l'âge légal qui nous donnerait à
l'avenir 10 points de plus chez les
seniors
et il faudrait que effectivement on est
défalqué de l'arrivée générationnelle
qui a poussé très nettement aussi à la
hausse de ce taux d'activité parce que
vous dites les taux européens on est
mieux avant 59 on est pas bien après bah
normal on a 62 ans déjà c'est vrai qu'il
y a les faits âge légal mais attendez
on est beaucoup moins bien quant au taux
d'invalidité à 60 ans 61 ans 62 ans par
rapport à nos collègues européens il
faut que dans ceux qui ne travaillent
pas on défaite les 20% d'exploitants
agricoles dont on va améliorer le calcul
pour leur retraite qui sont en
invalidité déjà le jour de leur retraite
et les 30% etc je vous fais grâce des
chiffres donc c'est à dire que non moins
bien
mieux à 60 ans mais moins bien après
parce invalidité une aptitude espérance
de vie en bonne santé très dégradée 10
ans d'écart avec la Suède voilà
merci et Monsieur Hainaut merci madame
la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur
je pense que dans vos propos vous avez
déjà répondu à de nombreuses questions
et puis nos rapporteurs ont posé des
questions un propos politique d'abord
quand la fusée par deux biais quand la
fusée par deux biais c'est pas simple de
la faire arriver à bon port je pense
qu'on est confronté à une réforme des
retraites dont les Français une bonne
partie en tout cas doute de l'urgence un
peu à cause de certaines phrases du
corps disons-le soyons soyons
transparents et éclairs et puis aussi de
la nécessité de cette réforme
de la nécessité de cette réforme et donc
on a une obligation de de pédagogie et
puis une obligation aussi de de faire
comprendre qu'il y a beaucoup de justice
en cette réforme donc moi je voudrais
revenir sur la question des des femmes
parce que malgré tout s'est répandu dans
dans l'opinion que cette réforme était
même si vous avez donné quelques
explications Monsieur le Directeur et
d'ailleurs pour partie aussi à cause
d'une phrase d'un ministre monsieur
Riester faut pas que c'est pour pas le
citer que cette réforme était difficile
pour un certain nombre de femmes qui
devraient travailler jusqu'à 67 ans pour
avoir un une retraite à taux plein et
donc je voudrais aborder la question
certains amendements d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée nationale sont dans le sens
de de trimestre valider de trimestres
cotisés et donc la question par rapport
à ça de d'une éventuelle surcote mais
alors quel est le coût de cette la
question de trimestre valider de
trimestres cotisés puisque quand on a
une une carrière en pointillée il peut
arriver qu'on est des trimestres qui
soient validés mais qui ne soient pas
cotisés à la même hauteur que si on
exerce son métier voilà la la question
que je voulais poser si vous avez des
chiffrages là-dessus parce qu'évidemment
on est confronté quand même à une
difficulté c'est que au plus on dépose
d'amendement ou de de ou au plus on
aborde la question sur l'angle de la
solidarité au plus et bien le le
l'économie ou ou la moindre dépense de
la réforme diminue en pourcentage or il
faut pas le cacher je crois que ça fait
partie aussi des de de des choses qu'on
doit dire l'équilibre du régime
forcément et l'objectif majeur donc oui
aux réforme de solidarité à condition et
bien évidemment que la réforme continue
d'être de participer à l'équilibre du
régime je vous remercie
je vous laisse répondre et puis ensuite
nous aurons une dernière intervention de
Monsieur vallerenberg
président
vas-y
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur je voudrais déjà
répondre à Monica qui m'a fait le
plaisir de me citer mais je voudrais
quand même préciser que la page 11 du
rapport synthèse du corps on parle du
seul donc pas du solde mais des dépenses
qui seraient sous contrôle
dépense sous contrôle avec quand même
vous l'avez noté aussi une baisse des
pensions une baisse relative d'accord
mais une Bescherelle réelle en PIB
dépensions donc je dis cette phrase dont
tout le monde se sert quand il est
opposé à cette réforme
et de nature à tromper complètement
notre regard à le biaiser si vous voulez
je crois qu'il faut que vous en preniez
conscience je raconte pas des histoires
là
c'est un problème de ressources et de
dépenses si je veux dire elle est
maîtrisée mais les problèmes de
ressources on est dans un système par
répartition par définition il faut donc
des cotisations
en priorité après on peut discuter que
les comment finance-t-on les mesures de
solidarité
et là on a la CSG on a des contributions
on a des impôts c'est un sujet qui avait
déjà été abordé d'ailleurs précédemment
dans la précédente réforme avortée alors
j'en viens maintenant après cette
remarque à poser deux ou trois questions
à Monsieur le Directeur
sur notamment l'augmentation des
cotisations je vous le déposez tout à
l'heure dans le couloir mais j'aimerais
vous l'entendre répéter ici si on
augmente les cotisations
employeures l'ensemble des cotisations
de 1/3 de points 0,33% ce qui est très
peu ce qui selon mes calculs
représentent 100 euros en moyenne par an
et par salarié est-ce que vous avez
effectivement un chiffre du rendement
effectivement cette augmentation sur le
calcul des bonifications enfin moi j'ai
calculé 3 milliards sur les bases qui
avaient été fournies par le gouvernement
est-ce que vous le confirmez sur le
calcul des bonifications
pour enfants
quel serait le coût pour le système
de d'un départ à sur la base des durées
de cotisation à 43 ans
avec effectivement la réfraction du au
trimestre pour enfant cesse trimestres
quand on a deux enfants et un peu plus
évidemment 24 si on en a trois est-ce
qu'elle il y aurait un coup évidemment
parce que ça serait sans décote et à
taux plein
idem pour les carrières longues
on est aujourd'hui en jongle entre 43
ans et 44 ans moi je ne comprends pas je
ne comprends pas surtout qu'il y a eu
une annonce de la première ministre 10
ans personne ne pourrait
après avoir travaillé plus de 43 ans
sauf s'il le souhaite bien entendu et
bien je dis quel serait le coût si pour
les carrières longues on disait tout
simplement par à 43 ans à taux plein
j'avais une question subsidiaire mais je
sais pas si vous avez la réponse c'est
l'augmentation des cotisations de la
cnr-a-cl j'ai vu apparaître ça quel
serait le coup vous dites ça n'a pas
d'incidence pour le régime général mais
ça a une incidence effectivement pour
les collectivités locales qui auront
effectivement à cotisé à la CNRS en plus
si je vous laisse j'en ai fini merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup à la président
peut-être sur les questions
d'articulation avec le consommateur sur
des retraites comme ça c'est Pascal
Breuil qui reprend la CNAV au corps elle
sera mieux que quiconque dire comment
effectivement il n'y a pas vous
confirmez même Lubin qu'il n'y a pas
absolument de papier à cigarette c'est
peut-être plus le terme qu'il faut
employer mais en tout cas que il y a pas
d'écart du tout avec le corps mais je te
laisse parce que
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
effectivement nous sommes un régime de
retraite de retraite parmi d'autres et
la différence que vous avez entre le 3,2
milliards qui est présenté dans l'étude
d'un pacte et bien ça n'est c'est
l'équivalent en tout régime de ce qu'on
peut avoir nous de notre côté parce que
le régime général vous le savez le plus
grand régime mais ne représente que
quand ils sont des dépenses
j'en profite pour vous dire pour
répondre sur la question des cotisations
donc nous sommes un régime de retrait
donc je peux vous dire d'ores et déjà
combien de milliards de dépenses de
retraite nous allons verser cette année
c'est 150 milliards en revanche nous ne
gérons pas les cotisations qui sont
gérées par nos collègues de l'URSSAF et
il y a de multiples autres ressources
donc nous ne sommes pas sollicités sur
ces aspects là
sur ensuite les différentes questions
qui ont été qui ont été soulevées alors
1000 pardon madame Lubin si j'ai semé
évoqué enfin employer un adjectif
péjoratif ou quoi sur le solde de la
branche retraite en gros pour moi je
considère que dès lors qu'on a un
déficit qui va tutoyer puis dépasser les
10%, c'est un c'est une alerte mais
effectivement c'est un jugement de
valeur et je le retire et je vous prie
de mon excuser d'avoir employé un
adjectif je n'aurais pas dû qualifier
j'ai sorti de mon humble condition et je
vous prie dans l'excuser sur la la
maternité
les majorations du réassurance les MDA
pour enfants donc ces fameux 8
trimestres donc deux ans par enfant
accordé au régime général et qui
deviendrait inutile
mais le son déjà elles sont massivement
inutiles et d'ailleurs je crois que
c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui s'est
saisi à deux reprises d'un rapport sur
comment rendre utile ce qui est inutile
mais son massivement inutiles pourquoi
parce que c'est majoration durée
d'assurance elle vise à permettre aux
femmes de pas attendre 67 ans pour avoir
le taux plein si elles ont le taux plein
par ailleurs par leur activité leur
elles ont tout plein c'est-à-dire c'est
pas des trimestres qui doivent
nécessairement être valorisés c'est des
trimestres de garantie encaisseur c'est
pour ça que j'ai bien pris la peine
d'essayer de préciser la maternité le
congé parental ça s'arrante dans la
retraite normale là on est sur des
majorations deux ans par enfant qui en
gros permet de dire si vous avez eu
beaucoup d'enfants vous allez pas
attendre 67 ans pour le taux plein et
permettez-moi du coup de faire ce rappel
pareil pour 64 par exemple on a déjà
beaucoup de MDA inutiles on a déjà
beaucoup de femmes qui en fait ont 192
trimestres et
il y a plein de femmes qui du coup se
retrouvent les super durer d'assurance
on a des gens qui ont plus de 200
trimestres etc donc 50 plus de 50 années
de cotisations entre guillemets mais
c'est pas la cause beaucoup d'enfants
c'est leur droit le plus stricte et que
à deux ans par enfant ça va hyper hyper
vite mais je m’étais pas même lui
pardonnez-moi mais le mais du coup voilà
le là-dessus la la c'est déjà le cas
c'est-à-dire que c'est majoration de
durée d'assurance c'est une espèce de de
garantie pour éviter le taux plein à 67
ans
et
là-dessus permettez-moi de alors sans
rentrer dans le détail du droit de la
retraite mais on a aujourd'hui
cet âge de départ à la retraite 7
handicap
carrière longue invalidité inaptitude
l'âge légal le fameux la SPA le Taupin
la réversion
7 avec des sous variantes parce que la
Racl vous pouvez à la carrière longue
vous pouvez partir avant machin bidule 7
sur ces 7 âge légal
sur ces septages légaux le présent
projet loi de financement rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 en
touche 2
c'est là qu'il faut bien voir aussi que
il y a beaucoup de sujets qui se posent
qui ne se posent pas quand on parle de
l'incapacité de l'inaptitude de handicap
enfin de tout ce qui est la question
l'inaptitude reste à 62 ans et c'est ce
qui explique j'insiste sur ce point-là
parce que c'est ces dispositions qui
expliquent les propriétés de cette de ce
projet de loi de financement rectif qui
explique que l'âge légal bouge
finalement pour les des cils 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 très peu pour les personnes les plus
modestes c'est ce qui explique que
l'effet financier soit majeur pour les
décisives 3 4 5 2 3 4 5 en gros un SMIC
et demi enfin les soient majeurs sur
cela et assez ingénitésimal sur les
autres c'est ce qui explique que les
seuls perdants théoriques à mes seuls
qui vont avoir une moins de retraite que
ce à quoi ils auraient pu s'attendre
c'est une seule catégorie les surcoteurs
c'est la seule
parce que finalement vous avez une comme
il y a Lewis
et donc parce que sur les 7 catégories
[Musique]
pour pour rattraper avec en revanche la
difficulté qui a été évoquée que ça va
être compliqué de les retrouver et la
suivre faudra qu'on fasse des diligences
pour communiquer et leur indiquer de
venir de venir vers nous
sur le les questions relatives au
minimum
c'est uniquement le stock parce que ce
sont des contrats des années 80-90
depuis en fait
non parce que depuis tous les contrats
aidés à partir des années 90 sont pour
le coup soit sont des vrais contrat
aidés avec une dimension de Travail et
ouvre des droits à retraite soit c'est
la formation professionnelle et à ce
moment-là c'est des trimestres de
formation professionnelle mais ils ont
déjà coup ils sont déjà couverts là on
parle les premiers contrats aidés depuis
les contrats 10 bars 77 jusqu'au
jusqu'au TUC après ils étaient plus
propres en termes de droit à la retraite
c'est un jugement de valeur par des mois
mais ils étaient en tout cas ils
garantissaient une forme de cohérence
entre l'engagement du contrat et les
droits à retraite donc là c'est plutôt
les années les années 80-90 il y a y
compris les contrats bars en dedans mais
les contrats bars ils sont beaucoup sont
partis à la retraite je pense mais ils
sont visés par voilà ils ont une partie
est partie à la à la retraite et
effectivement ces quatre types de
contrats qui sont qui sont visés sur le
minimum contributif
et sur le alors je vais me permettre
pardon et désolé si je semble si je suis
trop technique le minimum contributif ne
vise pas seulement qui ont ne vise pas
du tout ce qui est au cotisé au SMIC
ceux qui ont cotisé au SMIC le minimum
contributif il a deux étages il vit ceux
qui ont une petite retraite
et le miam contributisme majoré donc le
deuxième étage il vit ceux qui ont une
petite retraite en ayant travaillé à peu
près toutes leurs vies ou toute leur vie
en ayant cotisé
voilà exactement mais donc qu'on est
travaillé au SMIC ou pas parce que si
vous avez commencé vous avez fait 20 ans
à un demi SMIC et 20 ans à deux SMIC
votre moyenne fera que vous aurez une
petite retraite et vous serez impacté
par la mesure donc on n'est pas on
construit le catip mais pour construire
le 85 % du SMIC la loi de 2003 il
fallait une référence et a dit si j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie au SMIC ce qui
est effectivement n'existe pas enfin
quasiment jamais alors je dois avoir 85
% du SMIC mais en réalité sont embarqués
par le minimum contributifs des profils
de carrière très différents le minimum
contributif c'est le minimum de retraite
de base que l'on doit pour quelqu'un qui
a toutes ces années
et pour et ce minimum il est renforcé
pour ceux qui n'ont seulement toutes
leurs annuités mais on cotisé on fait un
effort contributif c'est-à-dire que
c'est des trimestres qui ont été qui ont
été cotisés et c'est vraiment comme cela
qu'il est qu'il est construit et conçu
ce qui explique les faits assez puissant
de la mesure pour le stock mais surtout
pour le flux ça explique que si je
prends le
l'impact de sur le montant moyen des
retraites les gros gagnants à la réforme
en terme de montant financier c'est et
c'est par hasard les D2 et les décils 2
et des cils 3 c'est les travailleurs
modeste les dessilles 3 donc les
Français qui sont un deux un trois semis
en gros il y a moyen de pension à terme
d'inventer en charge 7%. mais c'est
l'effet 7 % de gain moyen de pension
mais c'est parce que c'est l'effet mycos
c'est le plus 100 euros sur le micro eux
va pousser leurs pensions de manière
extrêmement considérable et alors
l'impact de la mesure flux elle monte en
charge très lentement puisque évidemment
elle est là après année qu'on va faire
partir mais elle elle contribue
elle a une elle continue à progresser de
manière de manière très nette on a on
estime que les gagnants sur la seule
mesure minimum de pension pour le flux
c'est en gros quasiment 200 000
personnes par an 130 000 femmes 70 000
hommes chaque année sur 800000 personnes
qui partent à la retraite alors ils vont
pas tous avoir 100 €. mais je veux dire
c'est cela qu'on va aller chercher c'est
le travailleur modeste enfin
je vais aller voir la troisième
quatrième décide donc
celui qui a une retraite assez faible et
effectivement le minimum contributif ça
va lui garantir s'il a bossé toute sa
vie que d'être à 750 le minimum de base
ce que je dois lui servir oui à 750 le
750 est devenu 850 alors après on peut
dire c'est trop peu passé j'ai pas
vraiment en juger et dessus il y a la
complémentaire évidemment qui qui arrive
pardon je suis pas du tout pas du tout
j'ai je me suis sans doute mal exprimé
je ne crois pas du tout à l'effet
horizon mais pas du tout
pas du tout mais vraiment pas parce que
l'effet horizon une espèce de
construction intellectuelle sur un
décalage mécanique du marché de l'emploi
or ce décalage mécanique pas du tout il
est pas mécanique vous la vitrez
justement il faisait fait structure il y
a une politique il y a une politique
employeur il y a des effets de la
réglementation en revanche qu'on a
constaté et c'est pas de l'effet horizon
mais ce qu'on a constaté c'est que la
crainte qu'on pouvait avoir en 2010
enfin j'étais pas là mais la crainte du
17h de 2010 était de dire est-ce qu'on
va pas avoir finalement plein de gens
qui vont se retrouver au chômage entre
60 et 62 ans le taux de personnes au
chômage qui partent à la retraite en
étant au chômage n'a pas changé à même
plutôt de diminuer mais ça c'est des
effets d'amélioration du marché de
l'emploi
il est de 11% de mémoire et
ce qui était au chômage au moment de
partir l'année de qui voilà avant ou
encore ou encore avant était au chômage
et c'est ça n'a pas ça n'a pas bougé
mais pour le passé range effectivement
pour l'avenir je ne pourrai pas le
garantir monsieur Hainaut sur les les
trimestres cotisés versus validés
en réalité il y a à la fois aucune
différence et beaucoup de différence
pardon là je je j'espère qu'il n'y a pas
réussi à avoir un sénateur initiatrice
de Normandie et j'abuse de de je suis
normand d'origine donc il y a pas de
respect vis-à-vis de la Normandie mais
le
quand on calcule une retraite dans avant
les années 80 en gros une retraite
cotisée validé c'était la même chose
c'était chez mes trimestres j'ai tant de
trimestres et puis on calculé en
fonction de ça un salaire moyen et on
faisait le mélange entre les deux ça
donnait une retraite de base dorénavant
donc en soi pas de différence en
revanche dorénavant beaucoup de
dispositifs plus favorables sont liées à
l'effort contributif les carrières
longues parce que les carrières longues
on va prendre essentiellement les
trimestres cotisés puisque c'est une
carrière longue c'est pas une durée
d'assurance long ce sont des carrières
longues sont des gens qui ont fait un
effort contributif supérieur à celui
requis ou justement tous ces
mini-mattention qui vont aller valoriser
le fait d'avoir une petite retraite
alors même qu'on a contribué au sens
financier cotisé à sa charge pour le
pour le système donc sur le socle en
quelque sorte il y a pas de différence
mais dès qu'on va rentrer sur des
mécanismes de amélioratif en quelque
sorte soit permettant de partir plus tôt
soit permettant d'augmenter sa retraite
là on va prendre en compte les
trimestres les trimestres cotisés
et enfin sur le
la question du sénateur sur les
bonifications pour enfants ils coûtent
des départs à 43 enfin si on prenait les
pour les départs à 43 ans les
bonifications pour enfants y compris
donc là on est bien sur les majorations
sur j'ai un enfant j'ai 2 ans de bonus
en quelque sorte on n'est pas sur le
congé parental et sur la maternité on
est bien sur ces deux ans compositions
plus
sur le bonus de deux ans par deux ans là
on pourrait faire un chiffrage mais
d'emblée je peux vous annoncer qu'il est
colossal parce que vous avez 82 % des
femmes qui ont ce bonus parce que qui
partent à la retraite ont quasiment
toute eu des enfants que ce bonus il est
très souvent de six ans si vous le
calculez ainsi avec l'âge légal à 64 ans
ça veut dire que toutes les mers de
trois enfants il y en a quand même deux
ou trois ou quatre etc partent à 58 ans
oui alors ça mais on est encore on est
encore à 1,9 enfants par femme et qui
qui n'est pas et qui réparti
oui oui mais là c'est les femmes en âge
de procré elles ont aujourd'hui plutôt
30 ou 40 ans et donc les femmes qui
partent à la retraite sont des
générations qui ont eu plutôt sur une
fécondité à 2,4 ou 2,5 enfants par femme
on est encore
des boumeuses comme pas je dirais mes
enfants qui partent à la à la à la
retraite et
je pense que ça veut dire que enfin je
vais faire une règle un calcul de coin
de table évidemment qui sera démenti par
par ma voisine ma plus expert mais ça
veut dire que 40% des assurés 80% des
femmes ont de la MDA et elle pèse 50 %
la population donc que 40 % des assurés
vous a baissez leur âge légal en moyenne
de 4 ans donc là je pense que le il y a
nécessairement deux chiffres enfin ça je
il y a nécessairement deux chiffres
avant le avant le milliard c'est moins
de chiffres milliards nécessairement
parce que 40% de personnes avaient ce
mal à l'âge légal à 4 ans c'est mais je
parce qu'elle brille ne m'a pas encore
et enfin dernier point sur les
cotisations voilà
je te remercie Pascal
vous trouvez dans l'étude d'impact
l'effet d'une hausse des cotisations et
l'étude d'impact propose par exemple
enfin indique quelle serait la hausse
des cotisations nécessaires dans le
scénario qui est retenu par le
gouvernement donc avec une hypothèse de
chômage de 4,5% pour pouvoir
réduire le le
déficit qui est prévu à l'horizon de
2030 et la hausse elle serait de 442
euros par an en 2030 de hausse de
cotisation par personne ce qui
correspond à une hausse de 0,8 à 0,9
points voilà si on voulait entièrement
c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ça exactement
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
directeur pour votre présentation
dynamique et les réponses que vous avez
pu apporter à nos collègues
nous avons je vous rappelle que nous
avons une audition à suivre
donc je vous demande de bien vouloir
rester en place
et merci beaucoup pour ces échanges très
très vif et très très nourris et
passionnant donc merci infiniment